[Musique]
et c'est avec Julien chaïda bonjour
Julien vous commencez votre revue de
presse par un retour sur ce violence
survenu après le match France - Maroc
violence orchestré par une frange de
l'extrême droite radicale en France
effectivement philoméreux plusieurs
arrestations dans les grandes villes de
France et beaucoup d'inquiétude après
cette nuit de violence qui aurait dû
être une nuit de fête après cette
victoire de l'équipe de France regardez
cette une de Libé qui titres nuit bleue
et peste brune propos clair et assumé
par le quotidien car cette peste que
dénonçait notamment Albert Camus dans
son célèbre livre renvoie à cette
mouvance fasciste et raciste qui avait
marqué les années 30 notamment avec
l'arrivée du nazisme que lit-on dans les
colonnes du quotidien et bien que cette
inquiétude est lié à des violences qui
semblent très organisées il s'agirait là
d'une nouvelle génération vous voyez ici
de groupes muscul radicaux formés
directement à la violence je vous disais
plusieurs villes ont été concernées
Paris Lyon Nantes notamment et une même
cible à chaque fois des supporters de
l'équipe du Maroc mais les vraies
responsables de ces violences écrits
quotidien ce sont les chefs les leaders
de l'extrême droite française reconquête
d'Erik Zemmour et le rassemblement
national qui les jours qui ont précédé
le match et bien n'avaient cessé de
mettre de l'huile sur le feu sur les
antennes télé en évoquant notamment de
possibles débordements de la part des
Lions de l'Atlas des supporters des
Lions de l'Atlas quel que soit le
résultat du match résultat et bien une
fête gâchée et on est bien loin
malheureusement délais célébrations de
la France black bombers des années 1900
98 et comment la presse étrangère
analyse-t-elle ce qu'il s'est passé
alors je vous montre un exemple avec le
temps qui me semble le train un trait
alors attendez je ferme ça voilà
l'exemple avec le temps et bien le temps
qui journal suisse qui ironise car
écrit-il l'extrême droite et bien
voulait rejouez la bataille de Poitiers
lorsque Charles Martel avait repoussé
les soldats musulmans c'était il y a
très longtemps c'était en 732 finalement
plutôt qu'une bataille c'est plutôt un
coup d'épée dans l'eau qui s'est produit
nous dit le quotidien rien qu'à Paris il
y a eu de 160 personnes interpellées
majoritairement issus donc de cette
extrême droite radicale le quotidien qui
titres France Maroc le scénario qui n'a
pas eu lieu alors qu'on envahisse alors
qu'on a lancé des envahissements sur la
voie publique un peu partout quel que
soit le résultat
on revient sur le terrain sur le choc
attendu dimanche prochain entre la
France et l'Argentine vous notez vous
Julien chaïda que la presse semble
plutôt poussée pour l'alby céleste oui
c'est vrai il faut l'avouer mais on va
quand même être un petit peu chauvin
pour commencer cette revue de presse
sportive regardez cette une de
l'humanité du maquille pas franchement
habitué à titrer sur des de l'actualité
sportive et de quitter tout simplement
et 1 et 2 et peut-être trois étoiles on
verra bien ça rappelle en tout cas de
bons souvenirs la croix qui de son côté
justement évoque ce duel trois étoiles
puisque duel entre deux des meilleures
équipes du monde et aussi parce que vous
lisiez tout à l'heure et la France et
l'Argentine vont chacune chercher un
troisième sacre le dernier pour
l'Argentine remontant à 1986 avec un
certain diago Maradona et justement
c'est peut-être aussi pour une autre
légende Argentine l'occasion rêvée de
gagner enfin le dernier sacre pour
évidemment par Leo Messi de Lionel Messi
le l'attaquant argentin à qui qui a tout
gagné pendant sa carrière sauf la Coupe
du Monde et la le match de dimanche soir
on le sait sera sa dernière chance pour
obtenir ce
dernier sac en tout cas le quotidien
argentin olé en rêve et on voit ici
notamment les grandes figures du
football mondial on a bien l'auteur
mataus l'allemand on a Roberto Carlos le
Brésilien ou encore Iker Casillas
espagnol énormément de nationalité
différente qui rêve de voir le homécis
et bien remporté ce titre mondial sauf
que et bien forcément nous du côté
français on n'est pas forcément d'accord
avec ça l'équipe qui s'interroge qui
titres sur Messi le français puisque ça
fait maintenant quasiment un an et demi
que Lionel Messi joue en France pour le
Paris Saint-Germain et qu'il sera opposé
à son partenaire en club qu'il connaît
très bien notamment un certain qu'il y a
Mbappe et pour finir cette petite page
sportive et bien regardez pour vous dire
que justement qui a toute une France de
la presse internationale qui est contre
les Bleus donc là c'est 20 minutes le
quotidien français qui ironise en
titrant horrible bleu pourquoi et bien
parce que tout simplement
les Français qui ont déjà été sacrés il
y a 4 ans endos le costume du grand
méchant loup parce que ils ont déjà
gagné et aussi parce qu'ils pourraient
priver Léo Messi du dernier titre qui
lui manque je vous donne ce petit
témoignage de la part de l'humoriste
belge Alex visorel qu'on connaît bien en
France humoriste qui ne s'est jamais
vraiment remis de la défaite de la
Belgique il dit j'étais marocain
mercredi anglais la semaine dernière et
je serai argentin dimanche et si ça
avait été la Corée du Nord et bien je me
serais coiffé comme Kim Jong-un ça
promet
vous parliez des Anglais Julien chaida
qui peinent encore à se remettre de
l'élimination face à la France mais un
autre sujet majeur alimente la presse
britannique et ce sujet n'est pas
négligeable rien ne va plus dans la
monarchie britannique entre William et
son frère entre William ils son frère
Harry et bien c'est je t'aime moi non
plus j'aurais presque envie de dire
c'est Dallas qui s'invite dans la
famille royale vous allez le voir
regardez toutes ces une de la presse
britannique qui tire qui titres
justement sur cette guerre que ce
risque majeur pour tout le pays je vous
rappelle rapidement les faits et bien il
y a trois
syndicats qui ont tapé à la grève des
ambulanciers les 21 et 28 décembre pour
demander des de salaire en ce moment il
y a aussi des grèves des infirmières
avec cette photo ici qui fait la une de
la presse britannique là on est sur
métro il est temps maintenant de prendre
ses questions en considération ces
infirmières qui étaient en grève et qui
sont allés secourir un homme qui est qui
s'est évanoui devant elle donc qui a
rompu la grève pendant quelques temps le
temps de remplir leurs devoirs regardez
juste cette dernière phrase du Daily
mirrors en titre c'est comme ça que
c'est à ça que la compassion regarde
message directement adressé à
richissounac le Premier ministre qui
pour l'instant a refusé de céder aux
exigences des syndicats je finis chez
Ida dans la revue de presse de Paris
direct merci beaucoup au vu de presse
que vous pouvez retrouver sur notre site
France 24